announcing his rallies are going to be
up and running again
he's going to call it the save america
movement why not
obviously he's still feeling the power
of being 45.
so i'm very honored to say that my
endorsement means more
than any endorsement that has ever been
given by anybody
so my next guest was one of the first to
stand by president trump in 2015 and 16
uh by his side through his presidency
and is working hard over the last six
months to raise money for republicans in
house and senate seats
and maybe eyeing the white house in 2024
himself let's bring back to the show
former new jersey governor presidential
candidate
and he's on the board of the new york
mets who happened to be in first place
no coincidence
governor welcome back chris christie
great to be back brian thanks for having
me well it's good to know the
president's confidence is up
would you say he has shown the power in
primaries so far
with his uh with his endorsement
well sure while he was president uh he
was in a real force
as he should be um as the president and
the head of the republican party
and i think going forward in in the 2022
midterms
um in particular districts he will be
continue to be a big force brian
um in other districts less so i'm given
that he's no longer president but
certainly you know i think everybody
should want every republican involved
in a positive forward-looking way to
make
two cases why our ideas are better than
the democrats
and why what joe biden and the
democratic congress is doing right now
is so destructive to our country so you
know governor i don't know if you heard
him with sean hannity last night was one
of the first times i've seen him
interviewed where
he didn't bring up the 2020 election
much he said basically
i lost that election i might be running
for another election
it's a good sign i think for republicans
you
absolutely look what i've said all along
is losing parties look in the rearview
mirror
winning parties look through the
windshield towards the future and make a
case for why their ideas are better
than the folks who are in power right
now and to the extent that
president trump decides to get on board
with that and start talking about that
rather than talking about the past
that's nothing but good for our party
and for our country so uh president
biden came back and signed a piece into
legislation we have another holiday i
believe our 12th
and it's going to be juneteenth
celebrating the mark that when texas
finally got word and confirmed
that slavery was over is this a good
thing for the country
i think it's fine brian you know i don't
really have any problem with it
i'm given everything else that joe biden
is up to this goes very low on the list
of things that i can object to
i'm much more concerned about six
trillion dollars in proposed spending
huge tax increases uh weakness towards
china
those are the things that i'm much more
concerned about than what holiday he
puts into effect
just so much is changing in our country
even in your state of new jersey
in new jersey this randolph board of
education has decided to remove all
holidays from the calendars
they're just going to say off days you
know randolph that used to be
under your auspices what are they
thinking
it's insane think about this this all
started because they wanted to rename
columbus day
indigenous persons day and people in
their town objected to that
so what did they do it's not keep it
columbus day
take the names off every holiday
memorial day veterans day
labor day it's absolutely absurd brian
but here's the good news
i tweeted out opposition to it lots of
people in new jersey
have been doing the same and so i now
understand that they've scheduled an
emergency meeting for monday night
to take a vote to rescind this stupid
policy
i sent out a tweet the other day saying
either they need to rescind the policy
or they all need to resign
holidays mean something and we memorial
day
is named so that we do remember not to
forget
um but this is what's going on in our
woke society right now
and all of us need to stand up and speak
out against this stuff
because it's really awful for our kids i
just looked at these stats before i
hopped up to here today
in terms of people 18 and up in america
55
have gotten the vaccine i know that's
something you feel strongly about
neither one of us are doctors you got it
you also got the virus
what's your message to other americans
my message to the other americans is
twofold first off having gotten this
disease
it's very random in terms of how hard it
hits you
and once you get it it's very hard to
deal with from a treatment perspective
so you don't want to get covet 19.
secondly i'd say taking the vaccine is
like putting the seatbelt on when you
get in the car
it doesn't guarantee you brian that if
you get in an accident
you're not going to be hurt or killed
but it makes it much much less likely
in addition it makes it much much less
likely that you could give
covet to anybody else i think given
those things and the safety the vaccine
has shown
i would hope more and more americans
take the vaccine because i think it's
going to be good for them
and good for their neighbors but in the
end it's everybody's choice everybody
gets to make their own choice regarding
their health
but i believe it's the right choice to
make given everything i've read and seen
well if you uh follow any playoff uh
hockey
playoff basketball or the first place
mets you see this thing called people in
the stands
if it wasn't for the vaccine there would
not be which is all good news for you
especially because governor christie
gets on the board and the mets are in
first place by i think four games
i'm not sure if that's a coincidence or
not i'm putting my best person on top of
this story
i will see what we come up with governor
thanks for joining me
thanks brian you know leadership matters
baby leadership matters you are and you
are leading that team you and
jacob degrom i can't see who's more
important absolutely i haven't really
concluded who's really leading
thanksgiving i'll defer to jake brian
i'll defer to jake
everyone uh everyone except for uh uh
maybe cy young
should defer to jake all right thanks so
much governor meanwhile hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else